so the other day gigabyte sent over this
Behemoth RX
69 50xt and as you can see it has a
magnificently ginormous cooler on it and
uh this graphics card has been driving
me crazy since the moment I first took
it out of the box so what we're going to
do in today's video is I'm going to walk
you through the problem and then how I
tried to diagnose it and then we're
going to talk about gigabytes response
to the whole situation
[Music]
now my initial plan for this video was
to take the RX 6950 XT and the RTX 3090
TI throwing them in an arena dropping a
knife on the floor and just kind of
seeing what happened but then when the
6950 XT handily got its cheeks clapped
at 1440p I was confused that's not
supposed to happen right especially with
a game like Battlefield 5 which really
likes it some AMD GPU so I went and had
a look at some reviews and realized that
yeah my 6950 XT shouldn't have been so
easily handled by the 390 TI and then
after doing some digging the only
metrics of how my card was running that
didn't make sense aside from the quite
frankly crazy coil wine from the
card was the power draw figures you can
see here in the this Tech PowerUp review
with their Sapphire cards they were
getting about 390 watts of power drw
while gaming where I was seeing 290 wats
in fact that 290 wats was lower than
what tech PowerUp saw their 6900 XT
drawing now you may be thinking Darin
clearly the sapphire car just has a
particularly aggressive power draw but
Tech PowerUp also reviewed the gigabyte
version of the 6950 XD and their
gigabyte card was drawing 390 wats the
same goes for the review the tech ters
did on their gigabyte card more on that
later actually but there's clearly
something weird going on with my card
interestingly Digital Trends also got a
Gaby 6950 XT and they were reporting the
same max power draw of 290 WS that I was
seeing on my card and they were also
having weirdly low performance so it
seems like my gigabyte card isn't the
only one suffering from malnutrition so
having had a brief look at the problem
let's check in with past DAV to see how
he tried to fix the problem
[Music]
now I've tried a couple of things with
this graphics card so far I've tried
three different driver versions ddu
wiping in between installs that didn't
have an effect I also tried switching
between the different bioses on the
graphics card both the bioses actually
behave exactly the same which is pretty
weird uh I've even reinstalled the
firmware on the graphics card using
gigabytes firmware installer that didn't
help either uh I also played around with
pretty much every Power setting I could
find in the drivers and nothing's really
helped in fact when I go to MSI After
Burner and pull the power draw slider
all the way to the right I just get like
300 watts of power draw on the graphics
card so even overclocking it quote
unquote hasn't really done anything now
one thing that does concern me about
what's going on here is there's pretty
bad coil wine on this graphics card
worse than the 390 TI had it's so bad in
fact that the power supply is screaming
like a cat with its tail caught in the
door uh so the next thing that I'm going
to try and do is replace the power
supply I don't think that's going to
help with the power draw issues but
let's see what it does for the coil
[Music]
one well that didn't make a
difference even with a new power supply
it still sounds like a Geer counter near
the elephant's foot and it's not really
helped our power draw figures not that I
thought it would uh but it's really
weird because the back plate gets
scorched being hot but if you check all
of the temperatures they they all seem
normal and it it's not like it's
behaving like it's throttling right it
goes straight to 290 watts and then it
just sits there so I don't know I think
I'm going to have to get a different
bios for this card otherwise we're we're
we're
stuck good news I found a video by an
awesome Tech Channel called Tech testers
where they also look at one of these
gigabyte RX 6950 XT cards although
their's was behaving a lot more in line
with what you'd expect they were getting
about 380 wats of power draw as supposed
to the 280 of mine so I reached out to
Tech testers and I was like please can
you send me the BIOS on your card so
that I can Flash it on here and see what
it does and they very kindly did send it
I have it here so thank you very much
Tech testers I'll have that video Linked
In the description below so if you want
to go check it out it's down in the
description uh so yeah let's install
this bios on here and see what it
[Music]
does oh yes success and interestingly
you can see that there are actually
different bios versions so let's see if
this makes a difference a few moments
later wait why would that not have fixed
it that's so weird
I I have no idea what's wrong with this
graphics card uh let me let me try
another bios let me let me try again
again no that also didn't help I I am
very quickly running out of ideas here
to be honest I I think the only thing
that I haven't tried yet is let's let's
change the test bed out let's put a
different system in there see maybe
maybe that does
[Music]
summon okay well it's just launched in a
completely different platform let's see
what that does
[Music]
and then my final idea was to just tear
the graphics card down to see if there
were any obvious problems on the PCB but
considering that there wasn't any
throttling going on I wasn't really
hopeful and aside from the fact that the
vapor chamber just looked like a
forensic team's wet dream with all of
those fingerprints it just looks like a
really badass graphics cards PCB and
with my untrained eye it it looks fine
and after spending 4 days on this I
couldn't really think of anything else
to do so with that I think it's time to
quickly discuss what gigabyte had to say
about this whole
situation now the final thing we need to
talk about here is gigabytes response to
this whole situation uh now I reached
out to gigabyte the moment I identified
there was something wrong in my eyes
with the graphics card and then my uh
contact at gigabyte immediately
responded with wow that does seem pretty
weird I've reached out to HQ in the
meantime uh have you tried both the
silent and the OC bioses and which
firmware version do you have on the
graphics card uh they then got back to
me a bit later and they said I just had
a call with HQ and they just want to
know which driver version you were using
for the testing and like I mentioned
earlier in the video over the course of
the testing I used three different
driver versions all of which behaved
roughly the same at which point my
correspondent who again has been very
helpful through this whole process they
kept responding to all of my badgering
and stuff very politely so I I really
appreciate that uh but they said that
okay we're going to need some time to
figure out what's going on here so I
delayed the video uh to to give them a
bit more time but since then I've not
really been able to get any more
information out of gigabyte I emailed my
contact again this morning and I was
like hey um it's been four business days
can you at least give me an indication
of whether or not gigabyte considers
this Behavior to be unusual or not is it
outside of spec and uh they they
couldn't do that which is pretty weird
like gigabyte you made the product
surely you should immediately be able to
tell if it's beh
abnormally compared to what you intended
it to do like what and that means that
as far as I'm concerned there are one of
two things going on here either gigabyte
meant for their version of the 6950 XT
to just draw about 290 watts of power
while gaming and uh this card is working
as intended which would be pretty stupid
because if you look at benchmarks of
like a safire version of the 6950 XD
which draws about 390 watts of power
while gaming it barely outperforms the
version that this card replaces the 6900
XD which means the 6950 XD is already a
pointless product that you're paying an
additional $200 for you don't have any
Headroom to lose performance due to
conservative power and draw figure it's
like yeah so that's the one thing and
then the other option is that there's
something wrong with this graphics card
and gigabyte's not been able to figure
out what it is yet which I'm kind of
leaning towards that considering that
the tech testers C I mean they they
showed proper power draw figures for
their card and I again I really
appreciate you sending over your bios at
CU it it kind of adds to how weird this
whole situation is like why did that
different BIOS version not fix the power
draw on this card I I don't really know
what's going on um but that is about as
much information as I have on the topic
so thank you for watching let me know in
the comment section down below what you
think of this whole situation I will do
a follow-up video Once gigabyte figures
out what's going on uh it'll either be a
short or a full video depending on the
scope of the situation so check out for
that and uh yeah until the next video
thank you for watching bye-bye
[Music]